I've already been introduced you know
about me you know that I'm an alumni two
children went here but there's a much
closer tie to Hillsdale College than
just being alumni of Hillsdale and I
want to tell you a little story in the
next few minutes Larry mentioned if
you're at the luncheon that there's a
monument over in front of central hall
just a few hundred yards from here and
it's for those Hillsdale College
students which fought in what we now
call the Civil War but I want to tell
you that at the time that those young
Patriots were giving their lives there
was a man who also fought for the Union
Army and he was engaged in that conflict
from Anderson Indiana
his name was Gideon Daniel Searle now he
was wounded in battle but he was
unimpressed with the drugs that they
used to treat his wounds so he figured
there might be a business opportunity
there so he started to research those
drugs used for treating infection which
led him eventually to start a
pharmaceutical company and he named a GD
Searle & Company now his granddaughter
my wife Louise and I and the Searle
family partnered with this College
because we see the same commitment the
same standards and philosophy at this
institution as the surra family has
sought to follow for so many years
this school is doggedly persistent in
its goals and objectives
just as the Searle company was that is
why we invest these material gains from
the past into this remarkably fiercely
independent and effective College we
believe Hillsdale College will impact
our country and our world in ways we
have yet to see thank you Greg thank you
gunner those are beautiful things to say
I think the klar and Searle families
come to find out I knew that those were
great families before I knew any member
of them and the reason is I'm lucky to
know for a long time now
Don Rumsfeld who ran GD Searle for eight
years I think in the late 70s and to the
mid 80s why would we need to build a big
old dining hall that looks like that and
who's gonna come there why are they
gonna come there last year on the campus
7,000 people came to visit and the
reason it wasn't 12,000 is we don't have
any room they come to behold the
beautiful things in respect to which
they are qualified to live fully human
lives as mothers and fathers and
husbands and wives and grandparents and
daughters and sons as entrepreneurs as
people who make their living and guide
their lives and raise their families and
we find that things beautiful that help
us do that those are the things that
move us to tears now there's a great
motion underway here in this little
place it's very strange
it's the largest thing of its kind in
the college world by approvable numbers
in recent memory anywhere in the nation
love of the good and the beautiful is a
compelling force and wherever it rises
it produces overwhelming results